I just got to the Wits Creator Summit here in Salt Lake City, Utah.
I just took off all my makeup,
done comfy outfit,
hung out for a little bit.
Now I'm gonna get ready to go meet my girls, Andrea and Juju,
for dinner. So let's get ready.
Okay.
That was super anticlimactic, because I already did most of my makeup,
and I'm almost dressed,
but I can't quite get myself in.
There we go. Okay.
But we can do hair.
So I'm actually here in Salt Lake for what's
called the women in Travel Summit.
It is a travel influencer conference.
And I know what you're gonna say.
You're gonna say, Lisa,
you're not actually a travel influencer.
And to that, I say,
says who? Technically,
I do a lot of lifestyle stuff,
and since we've been homeschooling,
I really am doing a lot more travel content
just because it kind of lines up with what we're doing in our life.
So I decided to come here because a worst case scenario,
I get a couple nights away from the kids and hotel room
in a bed by myself,
um, with two of my girlfriends from home.
Or best case scenario,
make some connections and get some tips and have a lot of fun,
and it gets to do more travel content for y'all.